well we're hearing from the we're
hearing that the prime minister of
Israel Benjamin netanyahu's Coalition
Partners have given the green light for
a possible emergency government let's
get more on this from villain Marx he's
live for us in West Jerusalem there's
been a lot of rangling over this wartime
cabinet Villa what what is the latest
that we're hearing from
there La that wrangling may well
continue because of course we have no
details about the preconditions that
members of Mr netanyahu's Coalition are
themselves trying to place on the
possibility of an emergency government
remember he has this narrow governing
majority inside the knesset here the
Israeli Parliament and they now have
given him a conditional green light to
work with members of the political
opposition here we are still waiting to
hear from that political opposition as
to what they would like to see
guaranteed were they to participate in
said emergency government over the
course of the last couple of days we've
heard from some of these very
high-profile political opponents of Mr
Netanyahu many of them former allies and
who've served with him in previous
government saying that they would like
to see some of the hard right political
leaders currently in his Coalition
removed from the decisionmaking process
when it comes to the military strategy
the military operations over the course
of the coming weeks we don't know yet
any of the details about whether those
preconditions from his political
opponents will be accepted by Mr
Netanyahu we do know that members of his
own party have been incredibly upset
publicly criticizing members of the
Coalition they serve within government
including the national security minister
Mr itamar benav who they say have been
obstructing efforts to form this
emergency government which at a time
like this is facing a huge ground swell
of public support as an idea to take on
this military conflict now vum there's
also been some confusion over whether
the airport where the benorian airport
on the outskirts of Tel Aviv has been
hit by Hamas Rockets what is it you can
tell us about the situation
there so Laura many times over the
course of conflicts involving Rockets
from Gaza and I was down there early
this year you see long range Rockets
being fired from the strip they go much
much more steeply into the sky above you
they are often targeting places like Tel
Aviv with that further distance they
need to travel as opposed to the much
lower range ones that tend to be
intercepted by the Iron Dome in places
like azod and ashalon in terms of what
we heard over the last couple of hours
from Hamas they said they had targeted
the airport they said they'd launched
Rockets towards it Al jaer spoke to the
airports Authority who denied that any
Rockets had landed that may have meant
the Rockets misfired it may have meant
they were intercepted but in terms of
actual damage to the international
airport where flights have been
cancelled repeatedly over the course of
the last few days no indication that's
happened okay vill marks bringing us all
the latest there from West Jerusalem
thanks very much villum